la nouvelle le ma mort est prématurée
j'espère mais un jour ou l'autre on
l'annoncera et le fait qu'on puisse
l'annoncé un jour ou l'autre d'un tu
déjà toute vie et ma vie est évidemment
coloré par ceux qui s'approchent tirs 6
il est temps de penser à la sicile est
temps de faire la retraite la course
mais jour est plus qu à moitié fait plus
qu à moitié fait bizarre également
beaucoup plus comment il est fait alors
en effet je crois que j'ai aimé beaucoup
beaucoup cette vie et je considère sans
appréhension majeur le fait qu'elle soit
appelée à terminer au pire vous saurez
assez bien séduire la mort pour qu'elle
vous soit douce espérons alors vous
aviez répondu ah ok au questionnaire de
fin on va aller vite là bas parce qu'on
va déborder un peu je m'en excuse auprès
des téléspectateurs donc nous aider
vous aviez répondu à ce questionnaire il
ya cinq ans et demi d'ailleurs c'est
drôle dans une émission avec roger hanin
qui avait lui-même répondu au
questionnaire bon ça c'est l'eau alors
on va c'est la première fois quelqu'un
reprend les allées répondre on va voir
si vous êtes fidèle à ses répond au
contraire si vous avez changé votre mot
préféré le mot préféré le mot le beau
oui c'est ça la main dialogue des bosses
à l'aide de votre mon mot préféré c'est
nos maux bon là vous aviez répondu juste
le mot que vous détestez le mot impropre
levier détester c'était ordre votre
drogue favorite
le soleil vous aviez répondu la
littérature leçon landewyck le son le
bruit que vous aimez une voix de femme
vous aviez répondu la voix de la femme
que j'aime
le son le bruit que vous détestez écrits
de la colère vous aviez répondu le bruit
des autres votre juron gros mot
blasphème favori un gros mot mais un jeu
ana à l'époque vous aviez répondu devant
lui d'ailleurs connard sais pas j'ai pas
beaucoup changé un bout femmes pour
l'istréen nouveau billet de banque
laetitia casta ça ferait des sommes prod
nous a été plus sérieux il ya cinq ans
vous aviez répandu louis de breuil le
métier que vous n'auriez pas aimé faire
quoi que j'aimerais en faire aucun sauf
celui que je fais qui n'est d'ailleurs
pas un métier je vis répandu à l'époque
je n'aurais pas aimé être esclave et
encore moins mettre d'ex d'esclaves la
plante l'arbre l'animal dans lequel vous
aimeriez être réincarné un olivier un
chat égyptien vous aviez répandue le
chat de châteaubriant de baudelaire ou
de malraux et si dieu existe qu aimeriez
vous après votre mort l'entendons vous
dire à vous jean d'ormesson
alors s'il n'existe pas je peux vous
faire toute une volée de réponse très
brillante s'il existe ce que j'espère
est ce que je crois d'une certaine façon
je pense que la seule chose que je
voudrais entendre ans et je te pardonne
à l'époque celle que vous avez répondu
il ya cinq ans et demi à cette même
question
dieu vous disait entre pauvres imbéciles
et bien maintenant je sollicite son
pardon publiés
[Musique]